I meant more like let's could you turn
this way more like like the face no
you're going to literally face Oh like
put my tail towards the key I don't wait
like so I okay
I Group as a competitive swimmer my
whole life and I love the ocean and
mythology and mermaids and I found out
people were buying these beautiful
prosthetic silicone tails and just
swimming them for fun and I always
thought why not make a career out of it
and still have fun today I'm going to be
teaching two volunteers some of the tips
and tricks of what it takes to become a
professional merman I am super excited I
cannot wait I'm pretty sure I'm gonna
drown I'm nervous about my legs being
tied up I picture myself getting in and
just flopping down to the bottom okay
let me styling you guys as Merman today
Matt I'm gonna push you in this really
cool Michael I'm putting you in
something a little more fancy yeah
you're gonna have this so we're gonna do
some flash tattoos these are great
because they last in water they don't
wash off and they don't get fussy they
won't rip or tear on things yep there we
go so I think you guys are all ready to
put on your tails I've always wanted to
be a mermaid ever since I saw Bette
Midler be a mermaid in her stage show
dolores de la go to chicago I wanted to
be that so I'm kind of obsessed with
mermaid really now this is gonna kind of
like a stretchy neoprene fabric and
inside the foot of the actual flew this
is kind of soft it's flexible which is
nice right now I'm going to teach the
boy some easy dryland poses with their
tail so this is going to go to on the
stomach with your tail flipped up oh
wait there you go and then kind of prop
up on your elbows there you go and you
can flick your tail back and forth see
there you go you can point your toes and
it'll give a bit of a better line one
more one two
this is how we think mermaid pose just
like you know the lip out a little bit
helps
I always wanted to be a mermaid since I
was a little kid I love to swim I love
being underwater gonna be focus on now
is the basic swim stroke so you both can
swim yeah all right so the basic motion
is kind of like an undulation in your
body you're going to want to fight the
urge just like you kick your feet if
you're not gonna get and where and just
look very nice okay so the idea is it's
kind of mostly come from you know I'm
used to swimming with all of my limbs
and now we're taking two of them away so
I would just hop right into water pull
that's part so I would sink down or surf
the water you do I'm just gonna you got
it ready just in it you got it just
gonna go don't do it yeah you're good
that way up we come back now I'm back I
do believe in mermaids and I'm not
embarrassed
you can feel how the string of course
jeweler so fun I feel like I could do it
I could swim neither of us drown which
was my big fear he was amazing
fun I loved being underwater you know I
watched a little mermaid now is pissed
at her that she wanted to live on land I
was like she had a great under yeah I'm
not down with that I agree it's a fun
benefit oh can we do it like a tail
high-five yeah let's try it
oh god it's like right here we made a
series it's coming on November 18 please
watch it
get it here yeah yeah are there you got
it I think I got it
you can see it it'll be released 2015
November okay